[Music]
in january 2009 a person or group by
the name of satoshi nakamoto published a
little piece of software for free on the
internet called the bitcoin protocol and
requested that others eat it and
run it on their computers
think of this program as a
free virtual bank  for the
internet community anyone is free to join
it to send and receive a new type
of virtual currency asia and from other
users it
was driven by a problem that
had been trying to be solved for 20
years like sending money
electronically over the internet
the piece  missing but soon to be
created is the reliable icas system a
method through which funds can be
transferred from ave without me
knowing ave and I'm not going to know in the same
way that I can take a 20
dollar bill and give it to you in  hand before
bitcoin the only way to make
electronic payments was to call your bank
or a company connected with your bank
and ask them to e  They will deliver the money to
the other person however more than 2
billion people in the world do not
have access to a bank account and
so you cannot send them money
regardless of the value they can
offer they are excluded from the
internet economy this is important  because
access to financial services
directly correlates with
dignity, freedom and
self-determination even those who
have a bank account are not
always free to send money to
anyone on the internet if their
governments get along the money is simply not
going to happen to  across its borders
simply put if
you wanted to spend a dollar on the
internet right now almost half the population
of the planet would not be able to receive it from you a
digital home system would connect
human beings economically like
never before possible  a
form that would include all languages in a sim
lar way to the way in which mobil
telephony  l enabled entire nations to
bypass
landline telephone lines and achieve
communications that were previously unthinkable
bitcoin can do the same for banks
and financial services and can
empower millions of people around the
world
bitcoin enables transactions to take place on the Internet for the first time
internet that
are person to person without the need for
an intermediary between them just like
metallic money
satoshi offers a physical analogy of
bitcoin to get people used to the
idea
imagine that there was a metal as rare
and scarce as gold but that it had
a property  magic can be
transported over a line of
communication like sending physical
cash in the form of an
instant message but bitcoin is not a
dull gray metal it is a virtual currency
that takes the form of a number in
the beginning these bitcoins had
no value  and they were just
broadcast for fun by people
who were interested in  the idea as if they
were digital tickets to a fair
that did not yet exist little by little the
fans began to accumulate and
sell bitcoins for a fraction of a
cent only to prove that the
system could work once
bitcoin had a value no matter how
small and  therefore a price
became a powerful
social technology that gave birth to a new layer of
internet commerce that did not require or
even allow traditional money
a new form of freedom
had emerged witting was beginning to be
used by people who did not  had nothing to
do with its creation and no
government could stop it satoshi was
always worried that bitcoin would
grow too fast from the
start it wasn't about making money
it was about freedom of exchange on the
internet this growing
public acceptance of bitcoin and proof that it
worked gave  gave rise to a
secondary demand for bitcoin as it
began to be perceived as u  n
safe haven for part of the savings beyond
the reach of any government
so the demand for both
transactions on the network and
investment in the network pushed the price of
bitcoin to almost the price of an ounce
of gold in December 2013
of  gradually
larger and larger institutions adopted bitcoin as a form
of payment and eventually
forward thinking governments began to recognize it
as a payment method i am sorry i am
interested in understanding what is needed
to ensure that this innovation can
continue
i am here to testify because i believe
that  digital currencies represent
one of the greatest elements of
technical and economic innovation of
our time four years later in
december 2017 a speculative wave
pushed the price of a single bitcoin
above 10 ounces of gold but before we
get into the method of how  does
bitcoin work the question that assails
most people is how can a
number have value  or why someone in their
right mind would trade several ounces
of gold for a number
let's rewind for a moment and
think about money money is our
way of moving value over
distance or over time
within a small group of  trust
as a family you don't really need
money people give things of value in
exchange for the promise to return the
favor in the future
so money starts out as a
shared memory
the oldest documents we can
find show that
lists of promises were written between  people
known as ledgers
this is what we call digital
money money that takes the form of
written symbols or digits but this written money is
only good if we trust the
people we are
exchanging promises with so
when people traveled to far away areas to
making exchanges with people
he had never met fie whom he
may never see again he used d  physical money
instead this allowed them to
close deals and trades
immediately without needing to rely
on all types of physical money that
we have used throughout history
a trend emerges we ended up using
some type of treasure generally some
type of rare rock a typical  beach rock would
n't work no one would value it
because there are so many but every now and then you
find something more unique a
shiny stone a tooth a bone humans
have a tendency to collect and
hoard unique things
the value of these treasures was based on
the fact that  everyone knew they
were
rare rarity or scarcity is value remember
that if it were alone on earth the
value of treasures would no longer exist
think of this as symbolic value it
may seem strange to
value rarity but we all experience it
as children  we value the things that
others have and we
can't go crazy and mean everything
[Music]
until we discover  that there are many
copies of the same toy and it is no longer
unique suddenly we no longer
value it as much and it is no longer worth anything
we do exactly the same thing as adults
we value things based on how
unique or rare they are nothing to do with
their usefulness
you can see  that throughout history
each region uses its own type of
rare rock as money in its area a treasure from
one region is not always recognized as
such in another little by little as
humans expand throughout the world it
arises  a global treasure based on the
rarest of rocks precious metals
these were the shiny parts that
people found in rocks throughout
the world these shiny parts began to be separated
by grinding the rocks by
melting them down and extracting only the
shiny part like  pure metal we give the
name of precious metals only to the
rarest iron for example is very useful almost
everything is made with it but it is not
considered a precious metal because there is
m  much everywhere that's why an ounce
of iron is worth only a few
cents people pay exclusively for its
usefulness compare this to an ounce of
gold which is worth over a thousand dollars it's all
driven by its rarity
[Music]
precious metals are an
important shape  of money because they
began to be valued throughout the world they
work like physical money that
crosses all borders the value
of an ounce of gold does not depend on any
particular culture this explains
why those in power
have always tried to accumulate or  control
gold because it is a form of
global wealth so history is full of
examples of people in power
collecting all the precious metals
they could turning us into coins
with the faces of those who ruled and
incorporating them into society in the form
of wages throughout  from different
cultures history shows that those who
ruled realized that the
coins they produced did not have to
Being so precious
the most important thing about a coin was not
the metal it was made of but the
reliance on the number it was
written on. The Chinese were the first
to take this to its logical conclusion and
put it into practice in the 11th century
when they created a  source of money
from trustworthy numbers on paper
without any connection color or any other
precious metal
is exactly what happens now at
fairs money takes the form of
tickets
the chinese realized that the
best way to control gold  it was
forcing everyone to sell it at
the borders in exchange for
trustworthy paper money
just like at the fair you couldn't
go back and sell the tickets in exchange for
gold there was no connection between
them you had no choice but to spend the money
paper money in the economy
this was a brilliant idea it allowed
those who ruled to keep all the
global money like gold while
the people kept a local money that
it circulated within its borders
eventually all regions copied
that idea the result is the modern idea
of special government-manufactured paper known
as fiat
oney paper money that is not conne
ted to or backed by gold or any f
rm of physical value its print
ng is purposeful  by the government
that is in charge of controlling the
money supply and enforcing
its as long as the people maintain
confidence that our government is
strong and secure they will continue to
freely accept and spend their
money without questioning its value
that is how we end up with a  world
full of local fiat money currencies
that travel freely
within the borders of a certain country
dollars euros yen are the same each
country is using their own
fair tickets without any connection to gold or
any precious metal today
we rarely use money in  paper
about 90% of your money only
exists electronically so  that today
you can use money in numbers as
points these points exist as
your checking account balance which is
stored in the bank as a
trusted file in a computer known
as the ledger of accounts or
simply the ledger of accounts the
government and  banks are in charge of
creating, keeping safe and controlling these
numbers in the ledger and
that is digital money just a book and
someone you trust like a bank
to keep it up to date and sure this
leads us to the problem that we suffer online
since  the internet crosses all
borders and gives access to a
global community who is going to do the
digital tickets for the internet
and who are we going to trust to be in
charge of them
[Music]
bitcoin is the world's first fully decentralized digital currency
is the part of  decentralized of this
phrase in which the bitcoin key is really unique
is the way that
sato if you flip the
tra model  traditional trust instead of
letting a bank control the
ledger you share it with everyone
anyone in the world can
plug in a computer to download and
monitor the ledger this
computer would be known as a bitcoin node
this file model  shared is
safer than any
government bank might
think when a highly controversial document or image
leaks onto the internet
those in power have
learned that it is impossible to stop altering
or destroying that document because of the
myriad independent copies that
exist
bitcoin  is one of a growing
number of systems that turn this
transparency of the internet into a
security advantage but a bank is not just a
ledger it is also the
people who validate and update new
transactions a bank is a process
and people follow  protocols so you
can think
of a bank ledger as a
d  document live at any time
contains the history of all
valid transactions that define
current account balances bit with
automates this banking process with
software shared by all
bitcoin nodes called the bitcoin protocol
takes care of making sure the
history of  transactions is
secure and so bitcoin is shared software
that everyone
runs at the same time instead of having one
trusted computer doing it there is
no hub in the network
no central authority or
concentration of power and no actor
where there is  that investing trust is
exactly how colonies of
ants and bees work, which are
decentralized systems that occur
naturally in this case a bee is like
a bitcoin node all of them follow
the same rules and this
collectively results in the construction of
a hive  the hive is something that
emerges from a group of bees
following certain rules
bitcoin is like a
computerized colony where instead of
building a hive a file is built
that follows the growing history
of valid transactions
this file grows in small groups of
new transactions approximately
every 10 minutes on average and is known
as the block gain
to better understand bitcoin you have to
understand how transactions are
entered into this sein block or
block chain all transactions
are public so instead of sending
a private message to your bank asking them
to move a number from one place to another
your computer will  yells into a
public internet channel where all
bitcoin nodes are listening
two key things happen every time a
transaction is announced on the network
first every transaction has to be
heard by every bit node sells the
network and second every node  of bitcoin has
to have the opportunity to vote
on whether a transaction is valid or not
to make it  ue these two things happen
data did something very clever called
proof of work or proof of work
done the system slows down the
process by which new
transactions are verified by including
an extra workload between the
time a transaction is
first detected  in a node and
the moment in which it can be validated
by the network,
it does so in the following way: each node
collects approximately one to two thousand
new transactions pending
verification in what is called a
block, after this block of data is
passed through a  sort of a
symbol shuffling machine that sorts out the
data and spits out a short sequence of
symbols associated with that block
acts as an identifier for that
block we call this
shuffling process a hash function and call the
random result the hash
hash functions operate in a way
unpredictable but reproducible the same
block of transactions results in
exactly the same has  h but if
you change a single digit in the
original transaction block the hash it
will generate will be completely different
for a computer to perform this
hash function is really easy it can do it
in a fraction of a second but the
opposite operation is very difficult
because hash functions have  been designed
to scramble the data in a way that
makes reverse engineering virtually impossible
and this is the source of the extra work
for each block the bitcoin software
specifies what form the hash has to take
result will give us a small
number relative to which the  hash will have
to be lower this is an
extremely rare event within each
block an extra space is included for
the number that the bitcoin nodes
will have to find and that meets
the condition of giving rise to the
desired hash format find the number that
hash places we look for is like
looking for a needle in a numerical haystack the
best they can do  r
bitcoin nodes is to try to guess the
numbers as fast as it can until it
finds one that results in a
valid hash for the block in question
this is what this thesis referred to
as mining is a guess the
number game  says that the first computer
to find a lucky number
for the current block has mined that
block of new transactions
immediately after mining a
block that lucky node sends it to
neighboring nodes to confirm it
basically saying there are people i won
this race by  Please check that
all transactions in this block
are valid.
This leads us to the second rule that
all bitcoin nodes have to comply with
as soon as a bitcoin node on
the network creates and hears about a new
mined block from a neighboring node.
stops and checks if the node is valid
or not
if the bitcoin node finds
any problem in the block it
just ignores it and considers it
invalid if e  The entire block seems
valid, so what it does is
download it to the memory of
valid transactions, in
addition to downloading it, the node links it,
calculates the hash of the block and includes it
in the next block of transactions
that is being prepared to be mined,
thus creating a chain  between
blocks which we call block change
creates an information dependency
between all blocks
if you change is a symbol in any
block within a blog change the
change would propagate along the
chain until the end
so the history of all is blocked
transactions and all other nodes
will do the same either in an hour on a
block if it is not valid or link it to
the chain if it is
if all nodes in the network have added
a block to the end of the chain this
block will be considered  valid
this idea of voting in favor of a block by li
king it to the chain is subtl
but very powerful becau
e as soon as a node starts mining the n
xt block  it changes the speed
of growth of the chain to which it
is connected
so that the more nodes that try to solve
a block, the more likely it will be
solved before so that the chain
will grow faster the more new ones
are working on it
and this leads us to one of  bitcoin keys
the true chain is the longest chain
because the honest chain will be the one that
grows the fastest this allows
many isolated people to
agree on the veracity of a unit
because we imagine that most
nodes believe that block a was  the
most recent valid block while
only a small number of
cheat nodes believe it to be block b in
order to determine which chain
the nodes should trust we
simply need to monitor
which of the two chains is growing the
fastest as most  as a
whole it has a greater collective capacity
to guess numbers the
block chain will grow before the
b chain  loque b is similar to because 10
people rolling a pair of dice tend
to get 2 ones before a
single person a single person can
get lucky and get that result
from time to time but most are going to
get it more often this works
because  no single computer or entity
is more powerful than the majority
of computers on the bitcoin network
compared if google dedicated all of
their machines to mining bitcoin they would
get less than 1 percent
of the total network power this is
based on a  prerequisite that
most bitcoin nodes are
honest nodes
apart from doing this in good faith
satoshi knew there has to be a
fair economic incentive to motivate as many
people as possible to participate
in this network to achieve this
the bitcoin protocol rewards
first  node that has mined a block with
a small payment of the initial supply
of bitcoins right
now this payment is 12.5
bitcoins and it goes  gradually reducing
so that by the year 2000 140 all
the bitcoins that can ever exist
will have been created or mined
resulting in a maximum availability of 21
million bitcoins
[Music]
so the system finances
itself with the initial supply  to
grow and secure bitcoins
come into existence through miners
and then are dispersed to the
general public through open markets or
directly from person to person this is
how bitcoin works there are numbers that
flow through a spreadsheet
that everyone controls at once
to this day no one has been able
to successfully compromise or attack the
system even with hundreds of
billions of dollars at stake as
law enforcement and regulatory agencies
seek to enforce existing laws
can meet him this student
who lives with is not a company
you can identify an executive of
etcetera but not a project  of
free code and of a community if the first
wave of the internet in the 1980s and
early 1990s resulted in a network
that connected human beings
globally in a way that had
never been possible before soon the second
wave of the internet gave rise to
massive networks with billions of
connected people that were controlled
by a single corporate entity
through proprietary software the idea
behind bitcoin and some say the
next wave of the internet is to resolve
that edge and replace that entity that
requires trust and its software
owned by an open network that
runs on shared
free and open source software and is
available to everyone is based on a
new model where the crowd
takes control of the software we use
instead of trusting a third party
the issue that  remains in the dawn of
bitcoin is that the next thing
would be what would be your reaction to a report in which
the recommendation was  that we made
regulations on discounts is
reviewed
let's say 5
I think that would be a very good idea I
think there is some room to
clarify and clarify, for example, the
tax status for those included or at
least clarify the right of the individual
to choose the  currency that I want to use
as a consumer that is equivalent to
any other national currency as a
pure ni or first function if in the
near future the bitton protocol is going to
facilitate advanced payment services
no if experiments are being carried out
to provide additional non-
financial services such as
property management and identity verification
[Music]